OK.
We literally have seen people argue that it
is OK to crowd together in houses of worship
churches because Jesus is protecting the people
from Corona virus.
Remember this lady a couple of months ago,
six weeks ago, driving out of this Ohio parking
lot is a woman who just attended a church
service with dozens of other people, including
children.
May I ask you about your decision to go to
church, to be inside that building?
I wouldn't be anywhere else.
Aren't you concerned you could infect other
people if you get sick inside?
Now, a little.
Now I'm covered in Jesus blood.
I'm covered in blood.
Other people who don't go to this church who
you might encounter, all these people go to
this church, but you're going to be in places
where other crashes every day.
I'm so sick from what happened because I'm
covered in blood.
Thank you very much.
It turns out not only was that not true, but
churches, while trying to get coronavirus
stimulus money, are often staying open, causing
new outbreaks of disease.
New York Pastor Fabian Arius has a parish
that lost 44 people to Corona virus.
That's not cases.
Forty four deaths to Corona virus Bishop Paul
Eggan.
Steinar, from an Evangelical Lutheran Church
network, says that the pastors in their network
are reporting in some cases, 25 to 50 percent
of their congregations have Corona virus in
the south of the United States.
We've seen more of these huge evangelical
churches stay open.
And there's a whole bunch of examples, Kentucky.
There was an outbreak that started and then
moved from the church to g.e.'s aviation plant
in Madisonville.
70 infections have been traced back to a church
in Sacramento, California.
The full list is not so important, but the
point is churches have been huge epicenters
of outbreaks.
Some churches not all, to be super clear.
Some churches have been the loudest advocates
against the stay at home orders, wanting exemptions
from the large gathering bans, for example.
And yet, at the same time, they want coronavirus
money.
Houses of worship have received hundreds of
millions, certainly maybe even billions of
dollars under the paycheck protection plan.
And the reason is because churches are being
treated like any business or nonprofit that
needs funding.
So understand the hypocrisy here.
Churches want to be exempt from stay at home
orders because they say we're not like any
other business or organization.
But they say we are just like any other business
organization when it comes to peopIe funds.
Now, the truth is more complex.
Many of the churches that are seeking funds
have shut down or are doing only online stuff.
Many churches in Massachusetts, for example,
fall under that umbrella.
So I am not individually saying every church
is hip.
Critical because they are all against shut
downs and all taking BPP money.
That's not the case.
Many of the churches that got BPP funds are
Catholic churches and many Catholic churches
have been closing in accordance with state
guidelines.
But the special treatment has to stop guys
in the eyes of the law and under government.
We've already said churches likely shouldn't
be non-profits and churches probably should
be paying property taxes.
Now I have no problem if the church has a
school or a daycare, something that is truly
a traditional standard nonprofit.
I'm fine looking at exemptions there, but
the general blanket idea that by saying you
are a place of worship, you pay no taxes.
It has to end.
And in addition, in exchange for the privilege
of not paying taxes.
Houses of worship are not supposed to be political,
and often they are.
Rarely are there ever repercussions.
So I just want consistency.
If you want to be treated just like any other
business and get your peopIe money and all
of that, well then you don't get to say we
are different and we get to stay open as as
if we were an essential business.
Why would that be the case?
If you are special and you get to stay open
no matter what and you get to not pay taxes?
Why do you also get the peopIe funds?
And then more urgently, because really, you
know, I care more about lives than the money
component.
The issue of funding, taxes, all of that.
It's important, but it's not urgent.
The issue of churches as a locus for coronavirus
outbreaks, that is both important and urgent.
Very much so.
And I don't know at this point what can be
done.
There are actually churches that are deliberately
being defiant when it comes to coronavirus
and staying open.
And it has to stop because it's spreading
infection and as a result it is spreading
death.